what is the cloud its data its scalable
its elastic it serve us databases and
hard drives but it's bound in physical
data centers we're going to unveil
something that completely changes the
way you think about cloud
you know public cloud and you may know
private cloud and you might even know
about hybrid clouds and marketing clouds
and elastic clouds but today now there's
actual cloud introducing Google actual
cloud platform this is the world's first
cloud offering running on servers in the
troposphere inside actual clouds it's
faster it's more scalable it's more
secure and most importantly it looks
like a real cloud we're also releasing
an industry-first performance feature
storm boost storm boost draws on the
power of Mother Nature to give you our
persistent disks a 50% IAP boost during
thunderstorms and you can predict
storage performance right from the
developers console by monitoring our new
weather dashboard or you can just look
out the window Google actual cloud
platform is the culmination of
groundbreaking scientific research on
supercooled water droplets technological
breakthroughs in high-altitude ultra low
pressure chip design and operational
efficiencies related to the way we run
non terrestrial data centers I sleep
more soundly knowing that my dad is
30,000 feet above the ground
I just love that I can see it this is
the first step in an exciting journey
people say the sky's the limit but we
think bigger
the clouds are so pretty that's not just
a cloud honey that's Google actual cloud
platform okay
you